rescue workers pull a 95 year old woman
to safety in the city of wollongong
south of sydney torrential rain along
australia's east coast has turned roads
into rivers and forced thousands of
people to evacuate their homes
we asked the community to continue to be
vigilant this is a highly dynamic
situation
these events are moving exceptionally
quickly
um as uh was witnessed in the illawarra
um this morning
where we saw in the space of about three
quarters an hour significant downpours
significant flash flooding
intense rainfall in the state of new
south wales has caused repeat floods for
months several towns are still battling
to clear debris australia's east coast
summer has been dominated by the la nina
weather phenomenon typically associated
with increased rain
unfortunately we continue to be in a la
nina
event which we know for new south wales
means that we can expect to see higher
than average rainfall conditions which
is exactly what we've seen over the past
couple of months and we are expecting la
nina to continue
throughout the remainder of april
the extreme weather made worse by
climate change has raised questions
about how prepared australia is for such
disasters and authorities are warning of
more rain in the coming days
major flood warnings have been issued
for several suburbs in the south of
sydney while the entire city of 5
million people has been warned of
potential flash flooding this weekend
victoria gatenbee al jazeera